welcome everyone to Long crime daily I'm
your host Brian buckmeyer brother face
his brother this week in the Pike County
Massacre trial of George Wagner IV in
Ohio Jake Wagner is the state's star
witness recalling in chilling detail how
he and his family planned and carried
out the murders of eight members of the
Rhoden family and Hannah Gilly law and
crimes Angela Levy details the testimony
what plea do you wish to hit her in
count 7 to charge of aggravated murder
of Hannah main road
I am guilty of your honor that was Jake
Wagner on the fifth anniversary of the
murders admitting to his role in
murdering Hannah Mae Rhoden the mother
of his daughter and seven of her family
members Wagner pleaded guilty on camera
but opted against having his testimony
broadcast which is permitted for
Witnesses under a rule governing Ohio
courts Wagner testified quote I had
decided I had no other choice but to
kill Hannah he said his father Billy
Wagner first suggested the idea of
murdering Hannah May because the family
Wanted full custody of Jake's daughter
fearing she might be molested by
Hannah's new boyfriend Wagner told the
jury he fired the first shot at
Christopher Rhoden senior after his
brother George Wagner IV froze Wagner
said his dad fired the remaining shots
to kill Chris senior and his cousin Gary
Rhoden Wagner then said he shot Frankie
Rhoden and Hannah Hazel Gilly in their
home in the head as their baby slept
between them then he said he shot Dana
Rhoden Hannah May Road and Christopher
Rhoden Jr all in the head in their beds
Hannah May's newborn was next to her
Wagner said his father shot the eighth
victim Kenneth Rhoden but he said George
didn't shoot anyone as part of his plea
agreement Wagner LED investigators to
three murder weapons they were in
concrete buckets used to Anchor a Goose
house Jake Wagner said he and George
built as a gift for their grandfather
the goose house was on a lake on his
grandmother's property Wagner said he
cut up those weapons with a grinder the
morning of the murders attorneys for
George Wagner IV began cross-examining
Jake Wagner on Wednesday afternoon that
will continue on Friday for Law and
crime daily I'm Anjanette Levy
and joining us today is legal analyst
Dina Dahl and co-host Terry Austin Dina
the courtroom is meant for the people
and in what is probably the most
expensive trial Prosecuting the state of
Ohio the public has limited access does
that seem right
you know I think that's a great question
really the reason why we want Public
Access is to be able to ensure that our
justice system is doing what they're
supposed to do as you say here the state
is spending quite a bit of money in this
prosecution and it was kind of unusual a
way certain Witnesses are not being
recorded and that's really how the
public is seeing this trial because
there's such limited access to the
physical trial itself with all of the
news media and so when they take away
the streaming of certain Witnesses it
really gives the public an incomplete
view of what's going on in the trial
absolutely now Terry Jake and Angela
took plea deals to avoid the death
penalty for all four family members
including George and Billy but together
the Waggers killed eight people in Cold
Blood was this the right deal for the
prosecution to make
you know Brian on the one hand I
understand how the prosecution wants to
make sure they get a conviction here and
with the testimony of Jake and Angela
they are probably to likely get a
conviction because they are testifying
against their family members but you
know the crime occurred several years
ago over six years ago there's no
eyewitnesses there's no videos so that
testimony is going to be very important
for that prosecution but on the other
hand you know this is a very heinous
crime there were eight people who were
killed and no question about it if the
death penalty is for any type of case it
is for this type of case this is one of
the largest cases in Ohio and I
definitely think that there will be
people in the community and frankly
there will be people in the families who
think that the death penalty should
still be on that table all right we'll
see how this case continues thank you
both well police in St Louis are trying
to figure out how a young man was able
to get back a gun that had been taken
away from him and then used in a school
shooting police say a 19 year old opened
fire on Monday at Central Visual and
Performing Arts High School in St Louis
he had graduated from the school last
year one teacher and a student were
killed in the attack several others were
wounded the suspect was armed with an
AR-15 style rifle as well as a large
amount of ammunition a fellow educator
says the teacher who was killed put
herself between the suspect and the
students police had responded to a
domestic situation a little more than a
week before the shooting of the
suspect's home the police commissioner
says his mother wanted the gun out of
the house but he was legally allowed to
possess it a third party took the gun to
get it out of the home but somehow the
suspect got it back after a shootout
with police at the school the gunman
died at the hospital
a so-called Rogue nurse in North
Carolina is accused of intentionally
getting patients too much insulin to
kill them Jonathan Howard Hayes was
arrested on Tuesday he was a nurse at a
medical center in Winston-Salem
prosecutors say he used insulin
overdoses to kill or nearly kill three
people in December Hayes allegedly gave
a woman a mere fatal dose but she
survived then just a week later he's
alleged to have given a fatal dose to a
six-year-old woman and then another
legal dose to a 61 year old woman a few
weeks after that the District Attorney's
office did not say what the three
patients were being treated for but it
seems Hayes did not know them so far
investigators say they do not know a
motive but credited the hospital's
checks and balances system with helping
to alert the medical examiner's office
that something was wrong Haze is now in
jail without bond